[Music]
good evening table family and welcome
those of you who are new to the table
my name is Juanita Johnson and I'm one
of the elders here and I just want to
say hello good evening welcome we're so
glad that you chose to spend this hour
of sunday with us and I hope that you
have all had a good week and our staying
safe and yeah just finding ways to
connect with the world around you in new
and interesting ways this evening I have
only one announcement we want to
continue lifting up our meetup groups
that happen weekly on Wednesday evenings
this week I want to highlight our teen
girls group this is a group led by
Maggie Tilford and Maggie Porter and
it's for teen girls they do games and
Bible studies it is an awesome group of
girls so if you know of a teenage girl
youth or one in your house or one that
you know that could use some community
or connection or just a great group of
friends to hang out with at least once a
week digitally and check out our teen
girls group
I think Karen's gonna put the info in
the comments to reach out to one of the
Maggie's and they will get that girl
connected so yeah Maggie Maggie teen
girls group um I also just want to
remind you all that if you have means if
you have prayer requests if you are
struggling in any way please don't
hesitate to reach out reach out in the
comment sections this evening with
prayer requests or if you have something
specific or you don't want to you know
put it out publicly totally get that I
probably would be in the same boat you
can read it shout to brett or you can
email info at the table 2x2 org and we
that info email goes to the leadership
team so the elder team here at the table
so we
can connect with you and we can be a
part of meeting your needs and this is
the way that we have to be the church
right now and I think it's a really
beautiful way it does require some
vulnerability um in a different way so I
just want to encourage you if you have
needs do not be shy about sharing them
so that we can meet them so we can reach
out and connect with one another and be
the church so typically I would
transition us into worship and I would
pray but I find that to be really
difficult to do during pre-recorded
announcements so instead today I have a
poem that I want to share it the poem is
entitled what kind of times are these
and it's by Adrienne Rich I encourage
you to look up the poem and spend some
time meditating on it them and
confession this is I think the fourth or
fifth time that I'm recording these
announcements because of this part I
want to say that I've had a really
terrible week I've had a really terrible
two weeks actually hearing the news
about a mod Aubrey and Brianna Taylor
really wrecked me it's really wrecked me
and I think it's because we are in such
unprecedented times like what we're
going through is so bizarre and weird
that this type of injustice is not
bizarre or weird it's really typical
it's really kind of standard operating
procedure in America and it so the idea
that in bizarre unprecedented times
where we are all having to sacrifice
because of our shared humanity
in connectedness that something so
typical and tragic and awful continues
to happen in our country rekt me and so
that's also why I don't have a prayer
because I I'm prayin Amos I'm I'm
praying for justice and I am angry and
really sad and just over it so that's
why I have a poem for you and it's a
poem that isn't angry it's reflective
but I thought it was a good middle
ground between the way I'm actually
feeling and maybe um kind of the
distance some other people might be
feeling from these events so again it's
entitled what kind of times are these my
Adrienne Rich
she writes there's a place between two
stands of trees where the grass grows a
pill and the old Revolutionary Road
breaks off into shadows near a meeting
house abandoned by the persecuted who
disappeared into those shadows I've
walked there picking mushrooms at the
edge of dread but don't be fooled this
isn't a Russian poem this is not
somewhere else but here our country
moving closer to its own truth and read
its own ways of making people disappear
I won't tell you where the place is the
dark mesh of the woods meeting the
unmarked strip of light ghosts are in
the crossroads leafmold paradise I know
already who wants to buy it sell it make
it disappear
and I won't tell you where it is so why
do I tell you anything because you still
listen because in times like these -
have you listened at all it's necessary
to talk about trees so thank you for
joining us and I will turn it over to
that worship team hey guys we're
thankful to be with you guys tonight
and I hope that wherever you find
yourself that you are able to somehow
enter in maybe it's noisy and loud and
your house or maybe it's quiet and still
in your alone but I hope wherever you're
at you can take this moment to sit with
us and to worship a god who's present in
the midst of your moment right where
you're happy and so we just invite you
guys to do
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
I wanted to just talk to you guys for a
second about a couple bucks I can't help
but just kind of feel the heaviness of
what's going on from around us like
Juanita was referring to several of
instead of just caught me in tears this
week and then on top of all of that just
the same nation and no approach
situations like this where
it needs to be done and marry those two
things together so I wanted to just read
you guys this quote actually it's in
this book mom called small great things
by Jodi Picoult and um
I read earlier this morning and I just
thought like this is the creative
Jeffrey positions the kind of like two
contradicting things somehow finding
their way into the same moment that I
love about the way of Jesus um
the quote from the book says I wanted to
show her love has nothing to do with
what you're looking at and everything to
do with who's looking
[Music]
because I feel like that's what Jesus
says sometimes and for me is take the
ugliness of our reality and instead of
whitewashing instead of covering over it
[Music]
and we find ourselves not just focused
only on our situation in the Domesday
that's happening but the one who is with
us in the middle of it and the one is
evil with us in the midst of that is
there it took me to this passage that I
see
one of my family members post earlier
this week
and it's it's a package three and I
found the same idea of naming and
acknowledging our pain and somehow still
in the midst of that being able to
Christ not just missing our pain but
finding the love and the presence and
the goodness of God so I just want to
read you that passage and that I want
Maggie to play this song for us she
introduced it to me a while back and
it's so appropriate and I feel like that
she's gonna do and singing it because
in my life when I've experienced pain
and darkness
[Music]
in there I just want to read this verse
and then you guys listen to this song
and when I hope that as Maggie seems it
he would just receive it as a good
friend who is faithful to believe in
another day in a newness even right in
the midst of what you're experiencing
today
though the cherry trees don't blossom
and the strawberries don't Lyman though
the couple's are warm worm eater and the
wit wheat fields are stunted though the
sheep pens are shameless and the cattle
barns empty yet I will rejoice in the
Lord
I mean joyful and God my Savior
[Music]
Oh
my life you had a thing
[Music]
I love your voice
the fire
[Music]
oh my gosh you have been
my life
[Music]
[Applause]
the goodness
[Music]
god I'm so grateful that you don't
decide that you are afraid of it
aren't far from it thank you that you
walk with us sir fired
you are close in our darkness
oh god I'm so grateful that you make
space and room for us and our reality in
your love of our grief thank you for a
love so strong in forgiveness for our
compassion so fierce I pray that we
would find you in our moments as we go
through our weeks when we're under the
shadows then you would be the light that
we find we love you and we're grateful
for your goodness and your faithfulness
[Music]
you
hey good evening everyone
grace and peace welcome to the table
this is really what a beautiful
beginning to our time together tonight
thank you - Juanita and Maggie and Mindy
just for just just being you and
bringing your true self to this
community and that's like at the end of
the day that's I think really all that
God asks and there's and you open up
something for all of us in doing that so
yeah thank you so we are kicking off a
new series tonight as you saw and could
probably kind of already tell the the
theme of the evening and so the the
series title is lament giving voice to
our grief and that's kind of how I'm
defining element in this series as kind
of you know naming what's what's there
giving you know giving voice to the
grief in the pain within us and as it's
been mentioned you know between the
ahmed artery shooting the Brianna Taylor
and then of course you can add on top of
that everything with the pandemic and
you know economic struggle struggles
financial struggles and that's you know
I mean that's all just kind of layered
on top of you know like regular life
with just its own just challenges I mean
I know you know most people probably
watching not everyone but many of you
and I mean I know your stories and what
you're going through and I mean we have
it all you know from cancer to deaths in
the family to job loss to deep
depression
you know suicidal thoughts made all
sorts of things right like this is and
that's that's just what we were going
through before the last you know three
to six seven weeks and so it's just it's
a lot right now and so I think
I think this is a timely a timely series
but not even just because of kind of our
cultural moment but really I think just
for the American church in general this
is something we really need to learn
this miss capacity for lament theologian
dr. Soong qionghua he wrote a book
titled prophetic lament and he said that
the American church must learn that
quote God is present not only in the
triumph of our day to day life but also
in the suffering of our day today life
in other words it's not only in our
moments of breakthrough and victory that
we're close to God but in our darkest
moments God is present in the darkest
moment of our country the the most maybe
like ugly or challenging season of a
church or the worst year of our business
the most unbearable months in our life
family or your personal history God is
there and he's his ready
and present for us to to say what we
need to say he's ready for us to be to
be honest and genuine that's the word
that I think goes really well with limit
genuine it's this is not a working
something up um but giving voice and in
an honest way to what is within there's
a scene in one of the most it's sort of
overly simplistic but it's also very
quotable movies ever Spanglish where the
the wife played by T Leone she's been
messing around her husband he was played
by Adam Sandler and so this film she you
know she needs to confess she needs to
come clean but it's been just an
incredibly emotional day for her she's
been crying and so you know the mascara
is running and the hair is crazy and she
turns to her mother and she asks how do
I look
and her mom says
genuine and then she says you could use
genuine and I think that's the thing
about lament about giving voice to our
grief and our pain is that it's not
always pretty but it's genuine it's real
it's the truth
inwardly that needs to be expressed
outwardly and yet it seems that that the
broader culture and even much of lead
the church doesn't quite know what to do
with lament to feel so you know just sad
it's kind of its kind of negative and we
should be positive right and that's
that's actually the issue I'd like to
unpack tonight which is why the title of
my my message is lament in a culture of
triumph we live in a culture of what dr.
Soong qionghua who I quoted earlier he
calls it a culture of triumphalism
here's how this is my own kind of
definition of what he's getting at
triumphalism is this this very strange
need to project positivity to fix every
pop problem and appear the victor in
every facet of life and I might even add
to that at all times right and you can
and you can here by the way in this
definition that this is a problem of
emphasis because of course I'm not
saying right that in every facet of life
we should do the opposite you know
project negativity and don't try and fix
any problem and proclaim yourself the
loser in any and every situation of
course not what I'm saying is that to be
human means that that I'm going to
experience a broad range of experiences
in deep emotions and that I must learn
to make room for all of it including
times of deep and profound grief but
again if we're looking to like the
surrounding culture to train us
the art of luminance were likely to be
disappointed not because we live in what
Old Testament scholar Walter Brueggemann
he calls it a a culture of denial we're
all problems but problems this is like
in our culture there's an answer to
every problem there's a self-help book
you can read there's a pill you can take
there's a solution you can purchase and
I think this denial that it reveals
itself in so many ways in places it's
it's evident in the way we hide our
weaknesses and our frailty like you know
business so it's great never better you
know the the family oh they're great
flawless even in my mood never better
it's always never better it has to be
never better and that's kind of boy
right that's the slogan of triumphalism
never better everything has to be spun
towards the positive in fact this even
comes out in strange ways like even in
our avoidance of aging me getting older
no no no if I just work out enough or
you know by that skin cream or eat well
I can hold off a gene forever there's
there's a Christian practice which in my
my evangelical Christianity didn't
really engage this this one um
but next year I think actually as a
church like we should we should try to
engage engage this you might have heard
of it it's called Ash Wednesday so you
might be familiar but if you've if
you've ever seen people you know with
the sign of the Cross in ashes on the
forehead that's a Christian who has
participated in in this ritual so ashes
are of course a symbol of mourning of
death of lament which is why I'm Ash
Wednesday is the lead-in to the season
of lint which in the Christian tradition
itself leads up to Good Friday
right the day of Jesus death and and so
when you go to the church to receive
your ashes do you know what the pastor
or the priest whispers over you I mean
in like American culture its it's about
the most offensive thing ever they say
remember you are dust and to dust you
shall return in other words remember you
are weak and fragile and one day you'll
die talk about Burstein our bubble but
here's the thing that's the truth right
that while there is of course beauty and
goodness and yes God loves us and yes
Christ died for us and rose again yes
all that's true but also life is pain
and we will suffer and that's that's
what Ash Wednesday is is sane but it's
this it's this welcome into the season
of Lent into identification with the
suffering one Jesus um and yeah it's
it's interesting because you know
increasingly not many churches really do
Ash Wednesday anymore and heck just
critique myself I'm faster I've never
even offered it I think next year we
need to do it and and noticeably not
many Christians show up for Good Friday
right the day we remember the
crucifixion of Jesus but you know what
everyone shows up for he's their Sunday
right why because that's what we do best
victory celebration positivity that
that's the American Way and again am I
saying that celebration and Easter are
bad of course not no I'm simply naming
that Christians say like many alluded to
earlier
it holds these together it holds the
cross and resurrection together
it's Good Friday and Easter we don't get
too
choose you don't get to say I'm more of
an Easter kind of Christian and yet for
some reason perhaps it's the
gravitational pull of culture perhaps
she's just you know human nature to want
to focus on the happy I'm not sure but
even our church services throughout the
year they very easily has slipping into
a a triumphalism of sort a sort of
denial of the pain side of life as
theologian Fleming Rutledge says so much
American Christianity today comes
packaged as inspirational uplift sunlit
backlit or candlelit this is how KJ
Ramsey she's the author of this too
shall last
finding grace when suffering lingers she
wrote when we orient our services
thinking of church services primarily
around praise in the individual
internalization of truth we disciple
Christians to expect lives where
individual effort produces blessing and
when effort is not enough faith
flounders under the weight of our anger
in our fear scripture paints however a
far more textured picture of blessing
we're mourning hunger and weakness are
the backdrop of displaying Christ's
presence power in love i so appreciate
her language here of a of a more
textured picture i think that's what we
need in our lives we just need a more
textured picture a picture where
suffering and joy are present a picture
where lament is given its place rather
than being buried under a mountain of
denial and as we turn to the scriptures
that place in space for lament is exact
what we see I'm gonna give you a few
examples kind of from all over the
bible's this first one this is from Jobe
a chapter three verse one says after
this job opened his mouth and cursed the
day of his birth he said may the day of
my birth perish in the night that said a
boy is conceived that day may it turn to
darkness may God above not care about it
may no light shine on it oh here's a
passage from Jeremiah chapter 15 verse
why is my pain unending in my wound
Grievous and incurable or Psalm chapter
3 Lord how many are my foes how many
rise up against me many are saying of me
God will not deliver him in fact as we
as we survey the Bible will find lament
in the mouths of like someone in nearly
every single book roughly a third bout
50 of the songs are actually Psalms of
lament the entire book of Joe like from
the passage we just read above is shot
through the whole book is shot through
with words of lament the books of the
prophets contain lament even Jesus on
the cross in the New Testament quotes
Psalm 22 saying my God my God why have
you forsaken me now throughout the
series we'll be in different places in
the Bible but tonight I wanted to go
ahead and give you a snapshot of lament
from the Book of Lamentations so a lot
of people don't don't know that in the
Bible there's literally an entire book
devoted exclusively to lament and it's
appropriately titled lamentations you
can kind of hear in the beginning there
that you can see the word lament so a
lamentation is an act of lament of
showing grief of expressing suffering um
so I want to give you some of the
historical context for the book of
lamentations so imagine that in army
conquers a foreigner
he conquers the United States of America
and we now live under a foreign
dictatorship and imagine that that there
is no voting our leaders are now
appointed by the conquering Empire all
of our rights are gone our entire way of
life that we've known is completely
upended I mean it's like you don't even
know how to act anymore the whole
culture is is shifting underneath your
very feet you aren't sure like where you
can go in safety taxes go through the
roof the top 25% of our best like
thinkers and writers and engineers and
craftsmen and their families
they're instantly deported just gone and
this could be you know 25% of your
family and and then another 10 to 15%
are killed in the the war that happens
finally another 20% of people migrated
to Canada and Mexico just prior to the
conquest so that effectively imagined
50% of the country just gone and um I
imagine for a minute the psychological
devastation the emotional toll that's
the grief the writer of Lamentations is
giving voice to that that was the
experience of the tribe of juda that
they had in the year 586 BC when Babylon
that Empire conquered them it was a
national catastrophe now we're about to
read a large section and I'll admit
there are there are plenty of
theological cans of wardens being open
in this text for example towards the end
you'll you'll hear how the author
wrestles with our theology of God's
activity like you know what what does it
mean for God and me when terrible things
happen like was God somehow responsible
for this I mean was it his will that
that I suffer did I do something wrong
and then right at the end she says I I
think so I I think this was the Lord's
hand through the enemy Babylon that
brought this
now what I want to do is for tonight I
just want to sort of suspend our
judgment and the complex theologies
about you know whether or not we agree
that that was the case let's just sort
of bracket all those questions and
instead let's simply sit with the author
in their pain and that author is
historically it's it's attributed to the
Prophet Jeremiah and my hope is that
perhaps by hearing them give voice to
their pain that we'll find some language
for our own so lamentations chapter one
verse one says this how deserted lies
the city once so full of people how like
a widow is she who once was great among
the nations she who is queen among the
provinces has now become a slave
bitterly she weeps at night tears are on
her cheeks have you ever been there
listen isn't it at night that our pain
finds us like during the day we busy
ourselves and we block it out but but in
the quiet of the night it visits us
theologian Peter Rollins he says what we
suppress by day haunts us by night it's
keep reading verse for the roads to Zion
mourn for no one comes to her appointed
festivals all her gateways are desolate
her priests groan her young women grieve
and she is in bitter anguish her foes
have become her masters her enemies are
at ease that doesn't that doesn't it
rage you when you're trying to do the
right thing and and yet you suffer and
then the people who caused your
suffering
to be doing just fine like they're there
at ease
they're at peace they're gonna live on
they're gonna be just fine and yet they
were the ones who who caused this pain
you caused my suffering like how how
could this be why is it that that so
often the the evil ones the evil doers
like get away with it and and die
peaceably in bed at an old age that's
the that's the UM be experienced at this
writer is giving voice to verse six all
the splendor has departed from daughter
Zion her princes are like deer that find
no pasture in weakness they have fled
before the pursuer
in the days of her affliction and
wandering Jerusalem remembers all the
treasures that were hers and days of old
when her people fell into enemy hands
there was no one to help her her enemies
looked at her and laughed at her
destruction Jerusalem has sinned greatly
and so has become unclean all who
honored her despised her for they have
all seen her naked
she herself groans in turns away her
filthiness clung to her skirts she did
not consider her future and her fall was
astounding there was none to comfort her
you can hear how this writer is giving
is basically personifying the people as
as a woman and you can hear the language
of shame in the passage guilt is when
like I know I've done something wrong
shame is different shame is communal
shame is when I feel lesser than in the
in the community of humanity I'm I'm
ashamed in their presence verse 10 the
enemy laid hands on all her treasures
she saw pagan nations enter
her sanctuary those you had forbidden to
enter your assembly all her people groan
as they search for bread they barter
their treasures for food to keep
themselves alive look Lord and consider
for I am despised is it nothing to you
all you who pass by look around and see
is any suffering like my suffering that
was inflicted on me that the Lord
brought on me in the day of his fierce
anger is there any suffering like my
suffering in other words is there any
any pain like my pain any grief like my
grief I can't I can't imagine anyone
going through what I'm going through
that's lament and yet because of our
culture even our Christian culture this
language may make us feel uncomfortable
like hey I came to church to be uplifted
not for you to drag me down on but
mysteriously and we'll get more to this
our final week it's only in giving voice
to our grief that healing and hope and
action can bubble up afresh and anew and
and I think that's the point of this
passage and others like it it's not to
manufacture or create pain in us but
rather to put us in touch with the pain
that is already within and then to give
us language to express it and perhaps in
that in that place of raw honesty God
will meet us she'll go ahead and bow
your heads and close your eyes
I'm gonna go ahead and pray for us Lord
Jesus I lift up every listener and every
person who is in them just in the midst
of pain and maybe they just haven't
known what to do with it haven't known
how to express it haven't known that
they that they can that they're allowed
that they're allowed to be honest and
genuine with you and others Lord may you
create here with this community of
people who can make room for lament
people who know how to weep with those
who weep and aren't anxious in the
presence of hurt and pain well would you
expand our capacity for suffering that
may sound like a strange prayer but I
think that's so essential Lord would you
expand our our capacity for empathy to
feel with others who are hurting and the
capacity to tune into our own pain so
God made those who who haven't had the
words who haven't been able to really go
there and feel what they need to feel
and express it made this this season
this this series be a chance for them to
tap to tap into that and may you elevate
us all to new levels of honesty hope and
healing the name of Jesus Christ
the crucified and resurrected one I pray
amen
thanks Brett and thanks for hanging in
with this table folks I'm gonna say
something and I promise that it's
relevant the mic is right here okay so
my wife just introduced me to Golden
Girls last night and there was a scene
where Blanche was all upset about losing
someone that she loved and Rose says I
know grief it takes time and Dorothy
responds
please Rose listen if you're Irish you
have a wake you eat you cried you drink
you vomit and you're done if you're
Jewish you cry you sit you eat for seven
days you put on ten pounds and it's over
we Italians we scream we dress up a
donkey hire a band and that's that but
it's these southern Protestants who make
it a way of life and isn't that so true
like we grieve and then once we start
grieving we don't really know what to do
with that or where to go but we all
agree from time to time and however you
do it I think whatever your stage in
whatever stage you're in the one thing
that we want to take from tonight is
that it's okay like you're okay
what you're grieving is okay how you're
grieving is okay and we want you to know
that you're seen known and loved or
whatever that looks like so if you find
yourself in the midst of grief and
lament tonight I want you to know that
this one's for you I just want to be
okay
Bok Bok I just want to be okay today I
just want to feel today feel today feel
today I just want to feel something
today I just want to feel today you feel
today you feel today I just want to feel
something today I just want to feel the
day you feel today feel today I just
want to feel something today
open the oven you will see I'm a gallery
of broken cards I'm beyond repair let me
be and give me back my broken parts I
just want to know today no today no
today I just want to know something
today I just want to know today no today
no today no that maybe I will be ok
open me up and you will see I'm a
gallery of broken cards I'm beyond
repair let me be and give me back my
broken heart just give me back my pieces
just give them back to me please
just give me back my pieces and let me
hold my broken heart I just want to be
ok he'd be ok
be ok I just want to be ok today I just
want to be ok Bok Bok I just want to be
ok today I just want to feel today feel
today feel today I just want to feel
something to day yeah I just want to
know today no today no
know that maybe I will be okay know that
maybe I will be okay know that maybe I
will be Oh have a good week l well I
think it's time for us to say goodbye
well I mean not really because you know
we're online so I think we're gonna keep
the comments open for a little while
longer just so we can chitchat and close
out the night as we do that I do have a
benediction the Lord bless you and keep
you the Lord make his face to shine upon
you and be gracious to you the Lord lift
up his countenance to you and give you
peace I hope that this week is peaceful
for you all I hope that there are
moments of joy and laughter and love and
light in Jesus name Amen
have a good night